now we were looking at jean-paul Sartre
famous short and very succinct essay
existentialism is a humanism which was a
lecture that's given a sort of popular
piece to try to introduce people to and
these sorts version of existentialist
philosophy you make some reference to
Heidegger as well so I think this is a
really good piece for getting into Sarge
for the first time and making sense out
of some of the key themes jean-paul
Sartre existentialism and interesting
interestingly enough it starts out with
a sort of defensive which you might not
expect
Sartre is usually on the offensive I
would say most of the time and he's
responding to critics what were these
critics bothered well certain things
that they saw in existentialism they
thought it's morbid
they thought it was groundless they
thought that as a philosophy it sort of
focused on just the negative aspects of
life it doesn't give you a consistent
ethics or a way of approaching things
and sort of thought that he needed to
respond to this and he also wants to
appropriate the notion of humanism that
is philosophy a way of life approach to
things that would cultivate what is
truly human that's what our potential is
you unfold the human being and he does
make a good case for this
we'll see why not going to focus so much
on that aspect even though is it a title
what I'm going to focus on are certain
key things and right now I was slogans
from this piece there probably since the
most famous Bibles of Sartre man is
condemned to be free or man human beings
are condemned to be free that is that's
a thing worth mulling over but just set
by itself at risks to generating to a
catchphrase likewise in existence
precedes essence that's one of those
things were here that one what does that
mean existence essence monthly fill us
up what does he mean by those things so
we're going to look at that and then he
talks about freedom as the foundation of
values again it sounds very abstract and
it seems a little bit at odds with
existentialism as such given that
existentialism is a philosophy of the
concrete so we need to do a lot of
unpacking in order to make sense of this
and I have a place to start is actually
with the very first topic that he's he's
talking about after he gets through you
know a little bit of clarification and
then mentioning that there's two
different kinds of existentialism
Christian existentialism and atheistic
existential what he's going to do is
he's going to contrast three different
views in the game you might say well
he's an atheist why is he talking about
God
well because God plays whether you
believe in God plays an incredibly
important role in culture and thought
and can be used as a sort of explanatory
principle which is the way God in fact
was used by some people didn't even
believe it so he talks about Christians
doing things where God the maker and
human being is the thing made and where
that reason the human being has an
essence and he talks about us being made
along the same lines as any other thing
that's being baked so they says if one
considers an article of manufacture ask
for example a book or paper life one
sees that has been made by artisans God
who had a concession of it and somebody
did mine he has paid attention equally
to the conception of a paper an item of
the pre-existent technique of production
which is part of that conception is at
bottom a form formula would be the
essence so the paper knife is at the
same time an article producible in a
certain manner one which serves a
definite purpose it has all these things
built into it one cannot suppose that a
man would produce a paper knife
it was for and you know this is a
long-standing traditional conception God
created human beings and it created them
in a certain way with a certain essence
being rational animals mind and he
created them for a specific purpose to
go forth multiply to love and serve them
pick whatever you like to get to know
each other to realize the image of God
within them there's a lot of different
possibilities but the basic idea is that
there is some sort of discernible
essence that you can wrap your head
around say that's the function of a
human being and the human being is doing
as well then good human being they're
deviating from this event just like if
you're going to say good paper-knife
would be one that you can actually do
about scratch your ears it's not for
that try to use it for that you know
probably cut yourself for cutting paper
so good paper knife does that task well
bad paper knife doesn't do that so like
you says here in a case like this the
essence the plan the idea in the makers
mind precedes the existence so if we
adopt a traditional theistic view God
made God made me according to a certain
plan a general outline and then you know
maybe something specific to me and God
first he has that mind that it creates
me and if I'm doing well I will be
realizing what that plan is
and if I'm doing poorly I'm probably
screwing it up so didi
so he says when we're thinking of God is
the creator we're thinking of it most of
times the supernatural artisan and he
says whether we're going to card or live
minutes we always imply that the will
follow more or less
understanding or at least accompanies
and so when God creates he knows exactly
what he's doing so what if we take God
into the ditch and so we have full stop
[Applause]
in light they take out a true but they
put something else in it that does more
or less like nature processes you find
people doing this today with
evolutionary biology
you know the idea being that things do
still have essences and that we can
discern these when a thing is actually
matching up to its essence and it's
doing well it doesn't match up to its
essence it's do it for human beings
which have wider variation intellects
and we can think about Europe so you
know stone has in essence thrown out
falls down it really does make a choice
human being provoke them see what they
do sometimes they respond angrily
sometimes they don't put it but it's up
to them but those those frameworks would
still be dictated that it was still the
same basic human nature which we could
rely on which we could use to figure out
how we act it's good they had all those
sorts of things so he says in the
philosophical atheism of the 18th
century the notion of God is suppressed
but not for all that the idea that
essence is prior to existence something
of that idea we still find everywhere do
you row and Voltaire even in cons man
possesses a human nature that human
nature which is the conception of human
being is about an everyman which means
that each man is a particular example of
a universal conception the conception of
man in countless goes so far that the
wild man of the woods man is in nature
and the bourgeois are all contained in
the same definition and have the same
fundamental qualities I mean he talks
about this again a little bit later he
says that towards 1880 I'm not sure
exactly white picks that day but towards
1880 when the French professors endeavor
to formulate a second liberality they
said something like this
God is a useless of costly hypothesis
hypothesis so we will do with that
however if we're to have morality of
society in law by world it's essential
that certain values should be taken
seriously they must have a priori
existence so I guess is yes essence
being scribed in being no God's no
longer creating it we need it to be
there or else things are gonna break
down we have to go they must have an
opera or existence it must be considered
a negatory odd priori to be honest not
to line how to beat one's wife to bring
out those children and so forth so we're
going to do a little work on the subject
which will enable us to show that the
values exist all the same inscribed in
an intelligible heaven although of
course there's no God and he talks about
this in terms of radical term that we
use in a somewhat different way the
French this is an actual political
movement one that was sort of body
delight meant so he says if God does not
exist we shall rediscover the same norms
of honesty progress and humanity and
what disposed of God is an out-of-date
hypothesis for some time we applied the
of itself and again I think today you do
find atheists who are willing to say
yeah I God doesn't exist but that's not
a problem I mean as a matter of fact
religious people they're not very in the
world atheists are probably more moral
we could live out some sort of human
essence which can be realized and we can
understand a new reason sense mentor who
knows maybe through science well
existentialism projects both of these
views at least sorts of discussions
existentialism says instead
this is what you get
existence first you exist that you can
have an essence but there is no essence
out there available just waiting for you
to realize and God's mind built-in fear
of your body your mind your soul there's
knowing that essence out there waiting
for you in society if nature the
evolution process anything like that so
how do we get our assets well that comes
through a choice we choose to be what we
are
SARP sees this is a fundamentally
different way thinking about human
beings concretely and human beings
universally none of us according to
Sartre have an essence which is prior to
our existence
first we exist and we usually exist for
a while and then we decide on what our
essence is going to be so I've never
read a little bit of this
he says atheistic existentialism in
which I'm a representative and Sartre
declaring with greater consistency that
if God does not exist there's at least
one being who is existence comes before
it's essence of being which exists
before it can be defined by any
conception of it that being is man or as
high degree as of the human
reality so what do we mean by saying
that existence precedes essence
well we mean that first of all human
beings exists so they come into being
encountered themselves so there's no
longer to secure brute fact issah t-shir
existence it's now encountering once
elephants and this may not necessarily
be you know fully knowing oneself from
barking out process of self-discovery it
can be as trivial as deciding am I going
to be this kind of person in this kind
of first in this situation am I going to
be a good way or bad it's candy going to
motivate me or something else come over
baby
well I engage in cruelty or defend the
person's being all those sorts of things
those end up defining one's essence so
the human being surges up in the world
and defines himself afterwards if man is
the existentialists season is not
definable it's because to begin with he
is strictly speaking nothing he's not a
thing
sergeants you know famous work is being
and nothingness we're going to look at
that a little more closely in a
different lecture we have nothingness
within us we yeah and that's part of
what gives us our freedom says man
simply is then he goes on and he says
something which we're going to take up a
little bit more late greater detail Isis
not that he is simply what he can cease
himself to be but he is what He wills
and he conceives himself after
already-existing as he wills to be after
that leap towards existence man is
nothing else but that
makes himself it's really important when
it comes to start not to dissociate
these two things making oneself the
human being as self productive and
choosing these going hand-in-hand
no doing or making without choosing no
choosing without being expressed or
externalize your body in some sort of
action in some sort of doing of making
or behavior so he says man is a project
which possesses a subjective life
instead of being a kind of boss or a
fungus for a colleague long before that
projection of the self nothing exists
there is not necess it's by projecting
ourselves out through action through
doing which is chosen which is a matter
of our will that we become what we are
so we really are a product of our
choices all different levels not just a
single individual level but you know our
character is a matter of our choices for
the trajectory that we're following in
life is matter of our choices how we
interpret where we currently are and our
prospects is a matter of our choices
now I want to sort of skip ahead a
little bit we're going to come back to
this notion choice over and over he
talks about
[Music]
certain terms that Heidi brings up
Sartre is very influenced behavior by
the way interestingly after Sartre
breaks this up
Heidegger comes out says I'm not a
humanist I'm enhancing humanists so
smart is bringing Heidegger into a
conversation because before he want to
be he says one of the things that we
some of the key concepts that we have to
think of our anguish at the enemy and
spit what do these need I mean these are
all sort of negative dark terms that
people throw around they have a a
technical meeting first start one that's
it is technical but it is also rooted in
the kind of way in which we so he says
what we mean by English the
existentialist frankly states that man
is in English his meaning is as follows
when a man commits himself to anything
fully realizing that he is not only
choosing what he will be but is
therefore at the same time a legislator
designing for the whole mankind in such
a moment a man cannot escape from the
sense of complete and profound
responsibility so anguish or anxiety or
being caught it's not just a matter of
how I find my own essence sorry to say
he thinks that every single one of us
we're not only deciding for
yourselves will be or going to be at Bob
in our heart price we're projecting an
ideal for all humanity and that has some
some pretty stiff consequences so he
says you know a lot of people want to
try to escape from this you know so
there's many who show no such anxiety we
affirm that merely disguising their
English or in flight from certainly many
people think of what they're doing they
commit no one want themselves to if I
rob a bank I'm not saying everybody
should well I'm saying I should well
it's good for me this is really good for
everybody else if I'm cruel to another
person I'm not necessarily saying we
should all people what do you know what
if I cheat on my my wife or I get a
mistress and she got her with somebody
else I'm not saying that we all should
cheat I'm saying it's good for me to
cheat well it doesn't work like that
Sartre says if you're actually doing
something into your actions choosing
something you can't take the dodge of
saying everybody doesn't act that way
when somebody asks you what if everyone
acted that way you can't say that's not
the case this is in truth one a lot
always to ask myself what would he have
if everyone did is one is doing nor can
one escape from that disturbing thought
he's saying look if you actually do
something that you think is wrong that
defines you in a way that you see as bad
I'd say cheating
or lying or breaking promises or
embezzling you know you pick whatever
you want being a coward any of those
sorts of things if you're actually doing
that you're not only committing yourself
you're committing everybody else is
saying everybody should act that way and
that sets up sort of internal discord
it's within that makes you anxious so
nobody can escape from that disturbing
thought except by kind of self-deception
the man who lives itself excuse my
saying everyone won't do it must be ill
at ease is conscience from the active
line implies universal value which it
denies by its very disguise as English
reveals itself this is a very typical
Star Trek thing we're going to see this
running throughout Invisibles almost all
of us are in bad faith very few people
are when he tells good faith so we're
all engaged in some degree of
self-deception it usually because
certain characters are not usually very
good people but there is this idea that
we ought to be choosing what is in fact
good for everybody
so now this leads to another question
this again I'm still talking about
anguish or anxiety who then can prove
that I am a proper person
my own choice my conception of mannequin
mankind
well that's a real issue don't we always
say to each other who are you to tell me
that I should act this way who are you
to talk about that person over there
junk ass judgments on them Sarkozy
lammeter a human being that's what we do
that is part of the dialectic or the
process of freedom you get to do what
you want to do you get to choose what
you want to become but you don't get to
get away from having to choose and those
choices having consequences and those
choices expressing a certain moral
commitment so there's there's conditions
let me say that one more time because
this important thing for some you get to
choose what you want to do you get to
choose how you interpret you get to
choose what kind of personal a to be
what you don't get to avoid even though
you can conceal it yourself is the fact
that you do have to choose and in
choosing you're not just choosing for
yourself you're choosing a moral
commitment for everybody
and it has consequences and it expresses
what exactly expresses we'll come back
to the moment so this is English this
places us if you take this sort of thing
seriously this will upset you it want to
upset you so he says clearly the anguish
that we're concerned with here is
actually not the sort which is going to
lead to quietism or inaction that's an
interesting thing to say because one
could very easily wave if you realize
the enormity of choice
that are involved in one could very
easily waver between different
alternatives and say well this I don't
want to do that I don't want to do that
one either I don't want to know I just
can step back
that's still a choice
you can't escape having to choose
something and choosing inaction quietism
would be a choice itself cultures he
says this sort of anguish is the sort of
thing which is well known to those who
born responsibilities so when a military
leader takes upon himself the
responsibility for attack
sends a number of men to his death he
chooses to do it and at bottom it's only
him who chooses higher command isn't it
sending its orders but he has to
interpret those workers all leaders know
that English people who are running a
business professors who are teaching
students if they don't hide themselves
says it does not prevent their head on
the contrary is the very condition of
their action for the action presupposes
that there's a for reality of
possibilities and in choosing one of
these they realize that he has value
only because it is chosen so now I'm a
bath track we're going to come back to
to talk about vanaman despair but this
is I won't dig in a little bit more
deeply a little bit earlier on in the
lecture he talks about the relationship
between value and
choice so Sartre is actually saying that
it's not like this it's not the case
that the person and they true they
choose one good hire good good if I hold
them attracted that they find the hired
good more attractive because it's more
valuable so that discuss it is the
choice that is one way of looking at
human interactions and the way in which
human beings make decisions it's sort of
an economic model it's also one that you
see Thomas Aquinas sorry to say that
actually we are these goods ours kind of
topsy-turvy we don't know they're sort
of you might say on the same level and
it's the fact that we choose that which
makes that good that good that's
something worth dwelling he's saying
that we are actually the creator of
values he says one point to choose
between this or that is at the same
to affirm the value of that which is
chosen so so far up to the at point that
could be like anybody else you know
we're choosing this over there why are
we choosing this over that because this
is better and so because it's better I
choose it he's reversing the process
he's saying because I choose this this
is better than that we are unable ever
to choose worse what we choose is always
the better now here's where it also
comes back to responsibility nothing can
be better for us unless it is better so
unless something is in fact shows it is
something more for more than just for me
I'm not truly choosing it as good let's
go back now to the beginning another key
term which is getting high Heidegger
talks about being thrown into the world
and we find ourselves in our situation
again we have our existence before we
have essence we're thrown into the world
we don't choose that but we're
surrounded by a situation by others by a
world which antedates us and then we
have to choose within that matrix and we
choose what we make of that matrix we
choose what we appropriate to ourselves
and what we were jet we choose what we
pay attention to what we ignore and that
is how we work out our essence Sarge
interprets this to be saying that
because God doesn't exist it's necessary
to draw the consequences of his the
abstinence all the way to the end
what are those consequences well if God
existed we could look to God and his
plan and the essence that he gave us as
the criterion the system whatever you
want to call it for making sense
thanks for figuring out what the hell I
am what am I supposed to be doing what
is the meaning of my existence but if
God doesn't exist if you take God
completely out of the picture not just
in a halfway kind of approach the way
light secular criticized but if you do
it all the way across the board
then you get this famous dictum of DOS
to the ESPYs if God is God does not
exist everything is permitted if
everything is permitted then that means
like he says I'm going to read this
there can no longer be any good a priori
it is nowhere written that the good
exists that one must be honest
that one must not lie since we're now on
the plane where there's only met if
there was an essence before existence
then we could say part of that essence
is we shouldn't lie when we live
indianature ourselves if we exist before
we have essence and we choose that
essence it is a lie possibility that we
could choose a world in which all of us
want to be liars all of us want to be
complete cutthroat you know totally
opportunistic bastards that's a
possibility
we'd be choosing that for everyone
because that's what it means to choose
and how do we decide between the
different things that they could choose
he says man is in consequence forlorn
you cannot find anything to depend on
either within or without himself he's
without excuse so if indeed existence
precedes essence one will never be able
to explain one's action my reference
given in specific human nature there's
no in terms of man is free man is
freedom nor are we provided with any
values or commands that could legitimize
our behavior so this is the flipside if
there is no God everything is permitted
but if there is no God nothing is
excused anything goes but any one of
those things could still be wrong and
there's no one reason why you should
pick this over that because it's your
choice that makes it that good
so not only do we have the anguish this
massive responsibility being thrust on
us
we're also stuck without any criteria
we've been assignments gigantic a slow
you might think of it and then we have
no rules by which we're supposed to
decide anything cases we have to make it
up as we go along
that's abandonment so he says this is
what I mean when I say man where human
beings are condemned to be free
condemned because he did not create
himself yet is nevertheless at liberty
and from the woman that he's thrown into
this world he is responsible for
everything he does the existentialist
does not believe in the power of passion
nothing excuses oneself and we're going
to come back to that in a moment I want
to jump ahead now to the third and
heading area theme in the Marin
nice example so what is the third high
daguerreian theme he says its despair
what is the meaning they says well it's
very simple it merely means that we
limit ourselves to reliance on that
which is within our wills we focus on
what it is that we can do we don't look
for somebody on the outside to fix
everything for us we have to look to our
own resources within the sum of
probabilities which render our actions
feasibly sense if I'm counting on a
visit from a friend who may be coming
from train by train or by tram I
presuppose that the train will arrive at
the appointed time I remain in the realm
of possibilities but one does not rely
on any possibilities beyond those that
are strictly concerned in one's inaction
you know why because everybody else is
free so you can't actually rely on them
defining their essence the same way that
you do I mean you can choose to rely on
that if you want to but you're setting
yourself up for disappointment so he
calls that despair he calls it not being
as you think about what disappearance
despair is the absence for the opposite
of hope so this means a condition in
which one can that hope one can now
count upon others one cannot rely on a
matrix that will somehow work things out
for the best so we have these three
things anguish or anxiety abandonment or
thoroughness and despair now let's look
at the example that that Sartre actually
uses is a classic case and he's talking
about a young freedom frame and this is
going to illustrate for us a basic
principle and that's running through the
whole thing is hitting out at 7:00
tonight but I want to sort of coalesce
or crystallize
so he says I'm going to refer to the
case of a pupil and this pupil of mine
sought me out with the following
circumstances his father was quarreling
with his mother was also inclined to be
a collaborator so this is back to the
Nazis in occupied France he's a
Frenchman his father is invited to be a
collaborator his another older brother
had been killed in the German offensive
of 1940 and this young man with the
sentiments of a primitive degeneres
burned to avenge so he's got a drive he
wants to avenge his brother who was
killed by by the Nazis
his mother was living alone with him
deeply afflicted by the semi treason of
his father and by the death of her her
oldest son so she's very vulnerable her
one consolation was this young man but
he had the moment had to choose two
choices two different alternatives do I
stay with my mother provide her with
security not just financial but also
mental emotional or do I disappear do I
go off to England join the Free French
forces so it says he realized that in
creamy and in fact every action he
performed at his mother's behalf and be
sure of effect in the sense of getting
her to live
so not only ideas of these choices
different
different contents through different
circuits if he goes with it staying with
his mother he is going to help her live
anything he did in order to go and fight
would be kind of ambiguous they could
get you know washed away they could come
to naught you know that's that case of
disparity right we don't control other
people's actions he might be stuck
behind a desk for for the entire war so
what do they do how does he choose now
Sartre says this is not a simple choice
between two different actions this is a
choice between two different realities
she says he was hesitating between two
different kinds of morality on the one
side the morality of sympathy of
personal devotion to his to his mother
he can tell she needs it on the other
the morality of wider scope important
debatable validity there was something
about to be said for going off to fight
against the occupiers he had to choose
between these two what could help him to
choose well this is a classic ethical
question isn't it when we're teaching
ethics classes we're basically asking
this question what will help you to
choose and if we're teaching the section
on utilitarianism mistake well you know
Jeremy Bentham proposed that you should
do what will bring the greatest amount
of pleasure or least amount of pain to
the greatest number here's how you might
calculate that and then for teaching
calm let me say something like well you
know here's some formulations of the cat
comparative here's how we would use them
tricky to understand it first for
teaching virtue ethics we do a different
thing for doing some care we do a
different thing do those really help
people to choose sources and bottom them
in a certain way video but the only
reason why they almost choose is because
we choose them to help us to choose so I
mean let's stop and think about this
room this is analogous to this this
problem over here we choose good not
because it actually is it it's the good
as we choose it when we rely on ethical
principle or some sort of justification
or even you know moral theory we're
actually choosing to make that one the
one that's going to work for us there's
nothing about that that compels us to do
that to make it our guide we choose
marketer so you know let's let's
actually look at all the different
things that start talks about let it fit
into this he brings it up with with this
kid he says could Christian doctrine
help him to choose Christian doctrine
says active charity love your neighbor
deny yourself for others to choose the
way which is hardest well which way is
the hard broke Christian doctrine can't
sorry tell you what you want to do in
this case - who - you all the more
brotherly water the patron or the mother
can you decide it on utilitarian which
is more useful the gentle one of
fighting and for the whole community or
the precise
one particular person to live who can
give an answer that doesn't say good
Sartre says nobody what actually counts
is more useful in that case the
individual is amantha choose nor is it
given in any ethical scripture like that
notion ethical scripture right the
continent ethic says never regard
another as a means but always as the net
well this is where catching ISM gets
kind of tricky if I go with this choice
I'm treating some of these means if I go
with this choice I'm doing it too so
that doesn't get me out of the situation
either making me choose something else
instead
maybe we know their instincts or gut
feeling or something like that or as it
says a great passion maybe we wait for a
sign from God
well you know as you choose if you want
to use passion or emotion or feeling or
a gut instinct or something like that or
God that's you choosing to do something
that's you choosing to make that how
you're going to determine that and
that's choosing the kind of person that
you're going to be that's choosing your
assets and that's choosing what all
people want to do as well that's
choosing the essence of human beings if
you are relying on a sign from somebody
it's up to you to interpret that sign so
it still relies on their choice doesn't
it
what about if you go to somebody else
somebody who's smarter somebody who's a
studies moral philosophy full-time has a
lot of books on their shelves or you
know maybe doesn't Watson maybe you
should go to a psychologist
Sargent parasomnia for I have a
cognitive behavior therapy books
or maybe should go to a lawyer or maybe
should go to a priest or maybe you
should go to a self-help or somebody
like that and take what they have to say
as what you want to do well that's kind
of tractive is it there are people
sometimes we seem to have better
understanding but if you choose to
follow them it's still you choosing
because why do I choose this advisor
instead of this advice because I really
want to hear what this one has to say
now here's the point where I action
difficulties are because you know what
are you doing the case of advisors who
you don't you really respect but you're
not always happy with what they have to
say to you I think that those may be
cases that extra challenge starts doctor
but I don't want to roll out what I
think might be wrong about instead I
won't dwell on what starts actually
doctrine itself is one other theme that
comes up in this that I really want to
stress as well is this going back to
this notion of we are we make of
ourselves we are going to be choose to
be so certs says that going back to the
to despair we are what we choose to
become he says man is nothing else but
what he purposes he exists only insofar
as he realizes so it's not just choosing
in the sense of an idle wish it's
actually committed we're there for this
nothing else with the some of our
reactions
our life this this is something very
very important sorry and discussions
sergeant existentialism is not for
dreamers it's not for people to sit
around the cafe making plans and
actually doing nothing is for agents is
for people who we actually do something
and make choices he says this is what
some people say there remains within me
a wide range of abilities inclination
and potentialities unused or perfectly
viable they endow me with the worthiness
that could never be inferred by the mere
history my actions I'm so much more I'm
so much better than what I've actually
done I could have been something really
big you know if I if I have just the
right situation and come together Sartre
says you know what that's BS
you are which you become you are what
you've done he says in reality and for
the existentialist there is no law apart
from deeds of law no potentiality above
other than that which is manifested and
loving
there is no genius other than that which
is Express and works of art so if you
think that you know there's the Great
American Novel within you you didn't
write it guess what it wasn't in you you
chose to have answer according to Sartre
if you say that you love somebody you
don't actually show it you know what if
you say that you're a fair person you
treat people unfairly because you know
in this situation there's a special
exception in this situation special
attention you're not a fair person you
are what it is that you show in the
world that we all through your reactions
that come from choices so it says it
puts all of us in a position to
understand that reality itself reality
alone is relied dreams expectations and
hopes serve to define a man
as deceptive dreams aborted hopes
expectations on fulfilled that is to say
they defined them negatively not
positive so you know if you have big
prospects and you want to think of
yourself that way Sartre would say that
matters if you could realize it but if
you don't actually make an effort to
realize it that's just you sir if you
know floating around la la imaginary
land that you use to hide the fact that
you didn't accomplish
now when you know what that means is a
real good something that's actually been
generated in reality however imperfect
it is is always going to be better than
something nearly potential here is a
place where Sartre is different from
hiding her in a very important way one
which myself I actually adores Heidegger
said that potentiality is greater or
actuality I say that's what Sartre
that's death focus real things are good
imagine things are not good they can be
imagined as good but that doesn't make
them good they only become good when
they actually exist
when they're brought into being so he
says nevertheless when one says you are
nothing else but what you live it
doesn't imply that an artist is to be
judged solely by his works or because
there's other things I contribute to his
definition as a human being but if you
put the totality of those together then
you can see what a person is the last
thing that I want to hit and this is
towards the very end of this essay is
again these conditions of choice what it
is that an existentialist life would
look like so he says he's responding to
those who are criticizing so I'm going
to try to
avoid that he says in one sense of
choice is possible but what is not
possible as managers I can always choose
but I must know that if I do not choice
that choose that it's solely choice this
although I may appear really formal is
of great importance as a limit to
fantasy and Caprice again it's living in
an imaginary when I confront a real
situation and this is what our life is
meeting real situations not just
textbook cases not trolley situations
you know that philosophers like to toss
around real situations when I confront a
real situation I am obliged to choose my
attitude towards it I don't get to nap
shoot because if I choose not to choose
I still choose something I choose a
default I choose whatever been handed to
me I choose self-deception
I choose quietism passes so he says I'm
a sexual being ritzy able to have
relations with being of the other sex
unable to have children put Nina in a
situation where that comes into play I
have to choose what I'm going to do I
have to choose who I'm going to be and I
can't just you know defer it to somebody
else because that's a choice too
I can't just not choose passengers if I
just say want me to love my my feelings
takes away well that's me choosing that
so he says even if my choice is
determined by no operatory value it's
kind of
to do with caprese in our view he says
man finds himself in an organized
situation in which he's involved his
choice involves mankind its entirety and
he cannot other way choose it when it
comes to sexuality either he must remain
single or he must marry without having
children or he must marry have children
in any case it's impossible not to take
complete responsibility if I to take
some other examples I see some people
being bullied I can say oh that's not my
concern turn away and walk away I have a
whole bunch of different possibilities
with that I could like express some
disapproval of it I could you know take
my phone and record it but not intervene
I can intervene I could intervene in
different ways I can just try to get the
person away safely I can attack the
aggressor and try to beat them down and
make sure they will
again I could actually join in on
cruelty and you know hurt the person who
is being attacked worse these are all
possibilities and if I choose to be
paralyzed even the as a choice and I'd
be a responsibility and I am what I
based on that choice I choose my essence
in those situations to achieve on a test
or not do I apply myself do I go to the
library what books do I take out these
sound like trivial things but these are
the things that our life is made of
do I dare show my children or do I
ignore them do I learn an instrument or
not these are the things that make us so
he says you know when it comes to
morality we cannot decide a priority a
priori what it is that should be done we
have to actually choose that in the
situation not only to get to choose the
individual things we have to choose the
way in which we're going to evaluate and
that too is part of our essence that too
is what we're choosing for humanity and
now he says another thing - very
interesting about progress he says we
don't believe in progress
I sure there's technological progress
right I mean you know they can call up
cell phones now when you know twenty
thirty years ago
and other types of things over you know
tied to specific places
remember car homes were like becoming
big gigantic 40 years ago we have those
wheel phones long cords and the rotary
dial things that chip is that's progress
but the fundamental human condition does
not change does not progress in that
sense why now progress implies things
getting better things getting easier it
is no easier today than it was 10 years
ago and it was John Paul Sartre time
than it was this goes against something
that started to dissolve seems to think
that it was in the Middle Ages that it
was antiquity all human beings face the
same basic situation of choice of
criterion stressed having to choose
despite not having something not priori
perfectly reliable that they can use to
settle the issue for them since man is
always in seeing facing the situation
which is always changing and choice
always remains a choice in the situation
the moral true problem has not changed
since the time when when it was a choice
between slavery and anti-slavery you can
pick anything that you want
we have always faced the same basic
situation of choice the and we face the
same types and temptations of
self-deception I'm not going to talk
much about about those in part because
sorry is going to talk about that other
works that you're going to look at so
that's we're going to leave off
hopefully this has been a you
introduction to some of the key themes
of jean-paul starts but and you see how
they hold together at the very center is
the notion that the human being is
freedom